All right, so we're doing the appendix today. We're done with all the series, and we're doing
the the the way that the appendix is set up is that there are actually two appendixes: one is the
simulacrum in ancient philosophy, and the second one is phantasm in modern literature, and there are
two essays a part of each appendix, so we're doing the first one, Plato in the simulacrum, and Lucretius
and the simulacrum. Um, I I didn't read the second one on phantasm and and modern literature, you know,
since you guys didn't read that one, we don't have to talk about it in detail, but I think
they're like, I texted there's just a couple themes that run throughout both appendices
that are worth talking about, you know, the eternal return, um, pure repetition as opposed to
the Hegelian, his version of the Hegelian repetition, or the Aufhebung, um, and then of course the
reversal of Plato and and that sort of thing. So that that that runs throughout both appendices, and
he he uses Klossowski in the second one, which I'm I'm not familiar with his work at all, but I know
that Foucault wrote an essay about him and they seem to like him as sort of a thinker of difference
as opposed to identity. So yeah, well there's definitely a certain response to Hegel here
you know, toward the end of the Lucretius essay, you know, it's he, oh yeah, like, well, explicitly very
briefly, but you know, goes full the chains, like the only thing, you know, it's about happiness and joy
and sadness and eliminating that the negative, right, and affirmation, yes, yeah, yeah. And there's also a
jab at uh um Heidegger um earlier in the Plato in the Plato section, which is uh philosophy doesn't
happen out in the woods within the forest while walking along paths, that's right, it happens in
the in the cities where simulate, you know, get out of the sparkle, yeah exactly, um, right, right, yeah, I'm
not I'm not going to find that sentence, but it was just this sort of like yeah, yeah, well kind of a
jab at like the notion of authenticity, I guess, too then, that's right, yeah, well, yeah, the simulacrum, right?
yeah, yeah, you know, um, and it's but I mean it doesn't name him, but there is that I didn't think
about that as a reference to Heidegger, but yeah, that seems right for sure, but that does I mean it just
makes Deleuze, it makes Deleuze a more interesting figure than I at least initially wanted to to grant
him because like with Derrida like they're they're privileging difference but they're not as does my
main target Barad like turning difference into like the uh kind of quasi reality, like the real, right?
you know, so there's a there's a treatment of difference as difference that's that's the motive
but it's not a vulgarization of the concept which is kind of how it tends to go in some versions of
you know, empiricism post-humanism, post-humanism, where you want to get rid of the dynamics of
representation and get to the hard concrete stuff of reality. Deleuze is just as interested in language
as he is in materiality, so it's like a, you know, there's no, it's just really weird to talk about
the hard stuff of reality and then call the difference, right? Exactly, yeah, yeah. Well, even his treatment of the
atom is sufficiently, yeah, that's fascinating. Yeah, because the only real experience with Stoic and
Epicurean ontology that I I have is just sort of like like the treatments of of atomism and, you know,
like all right if like I love the Greeks thinking about atomism in a way that like Newtonian and sort
of like more contemporary for until you get to quantum physics, I just find a little bit dumb because it's like
all right, if you're gonna follow this this training of thought, if everything is composed of something
smaller, then well shit, if atoms are everything then how does anything move? How do the atoms actually
move? And then you're like, all right, well, they move each other around, or they're, you know, then you have
to have a concept of nothingness, so there's a vacuum and stuff moves in there, but then does the
nothingness get moved by the atoms? And you know, so so that you know, I I get and I can sort of think
around the clinamen, this the swerve, where he's talking about, you know, like, and this I think he
actually does attach it to Lucretius, but there it has a little bit of a resonance, you know, the the
Epicurean atom that swerves has a little bit of a resonance with the with the monad that has its own
sort of like built-in inclinations, right? Um, right, I still just like this it's just hard for me to
think this the swerve and the and even to the implications for this work. So when I read Lucretius
for example, like the first three-ish pages just totally clicked for me that you know, it just seemed
like almost a an overview of a differential ontology and then the last three pages totally clicked for me
because it was you know, a connection between a differential ontology and an ethics of affirmation
but the middle three pages about the swerve and the five infinities and the three infinitudes and all
like yeah what the hell is going on, uh, yeah, the specifics of that especially when it's directly
about nap the natural physical world i'm kind of like yeah i mean he does relate it to thought
processes and differential relations in terms of cognition which is which i'm much more familiar
with i mean the clenamen is also it's either a concept of like fictus or shellings he uses it as
well but in that in the sense of like the the swerving of thinking and like thought relations or
thought determinations i can kind of get a hold of that but when it's just talking about atoms uh i'm
kind of like well i mean okay they swerve but what is that i can get it in a poetic sense i just i can't
get it in a more like physical i'm like okay they swerve now why what is that swerve is that they
curving into each other what are they they're colliding i i don't know anything well they do collide
and you know like that would be a sort of a reductive atomism where you know sort of like
newtonian atomism where you know atoms you know objects hit each other and you know and there's a
predictable geometric you know action and reaction and all right so if i hit it at this angle then you
know the billiard ball is going to go off at that angle at that velocity um you know whatever
but the swerve is internal like in so far as we can you know confidently use that term is
internally motivated and so this is a way that the two essays in some ways click because you know in
the first essay on plato he's like look it doesn't tell you anything of value about plato to say that
he cares about division he actually doesn't care about division he cares about a particular kind of
division a genealogical division and what really matters here is figuring out you know plato's the
motivations of of platonism and in some ways that's exactly what's going on with the atoms the
clenamin is or the clenamin i don't know like it's right clenamin is what i always heard yeah clenamin
um is that it's you know there's like the atoms have motivations and they you know they swerve in this
so that direction and sort of compound in and and and you know are repelled by other atoms you know
according to sort of like various possible combinations based on those motivations
that's that's interesting i thought you were going to go a different direction with the link between
the two halves and and that was towards if the first essay if the plato essay is in favor of the
simulacrum because its forces is an exteriorizing force and against the model the model copy relation
because its force is an interiorizing force the clenamin is an interiorizing of the differentiating
yeah force itself you see what i'm saying like uh that's what i thought you were going to do when
you said yeah i hadn't even made the link until you said i see the connection between the two of them
that's what i thought right because i wasn't thinking of an argumentative because i wasn't
thinking about their you know the targets in terms of making the connection i was just thinking like
all right here's like yeah it makes sense call it plato call an atom you know just following you have
to figure out their motivations and just you know documenting you know the fact that one divides and
the other one moves isn't good enough right yeah i mean i i was sort of expecting a more explicit
deconstruction of the notion of the atom in that section just because that would seem self-evident
with Deleuze's approach like the atom is considered an identity and he does sort of say that right up
front right the atom is to thought what the sensible object is to the senses it is the object which is
essentially addressed the thought the object which gives food to thought right so that kind of uh
vulgar phenomenological account of the understanding we we posit objects that's kind of what Deleuze wants to
get away from in some sense right and so but i get could you say that he wants to consider the atom
at the level of the singularity i mean is that a solution to the issue of it being considered an identity
you know because he's not like getting rid of the idea of the atom you know this is where it got i was
like trying to hold all of that stuff you know that like that particular passage that you're referring to
you know i was like i was like holding on to it like thinking like all right this is going to get
complicated because this it sounds a whole lot like a sort of a substance based notion of the atom
and if Deleuze is interested in this it just is not going to remain that and at the bottom of page 273
he's talking about the emissions of elements and this whole sort of like secondary order of atoms and
thinking about the relationship between like attributes uh things that we would normally
attribute to you know properties that we would attribute to substances he starts talking about
how you know like the depths of bodies emit elements that are passed through the surface and there's like
this whole, you know, phenomenological dimension to that, but it's all kind of based on a physics of
speed and angle and direction and, you know, like noises are noises until they're sort of
shaped and passed through the orifice of the mouth and are articulated and, you know, what I sort of was
getting a clearer and clearer sense of, there is a thoroughly differential sense of the atom, uh, like
atoms are not substance at all. Atoms are are intensities. I mean, they're they're they're swerves of movement
which I'm now increasingly thinking of the word swerve as just like a style of movement or a kind of
movement, whereas I would look at a singularity more as sort of like the intersection between two atoms
colliding. So like to think about a singularity or sense or anything else like that, you you need a
differential, right? You, so you need more, you need movements colliding, right? Yeah. So a singularity
would be more of like the concretizing of a relation, whereas the atom at least in this formulation is
almost a non-relation or the potential for relations. It's not the relation itself. It's like the movement
that might produce relations. Well, I'm gonna guess there's an infinite regress thing here was like, hey, if you
look at, you know, an atom is probably composed of other atoms, right? Yeah, right. Just like if you look at a
series, you know, is composed of other series, and so it's differential all the way down. Yeah, but yeah
you could say that you know, an atom is the event only of other of their atoms converging and diverging
and and I I I mean what interest in there? I mean that's the part, I mean I I had a similar version
of this essay as both of you guys like and and you know what's funny is as I was reading the very
beginning of it last week and I thought Nathaniel's gonna love this. I really did. That was a thought that
occurred like he's gonna be just totally all over this uh in that first few pages. I'm like it just
sounds like how Nathaniel thinks the Lucretius one. Yeah, the Lucretius one, um, but the the section
that you're at right now he's interested in the emissions from the atoms, right? And he's using the
concept of the emission there to undermine the notion of the atom as an entity that emits, right? You know
so it's the the relation between the depth and the in the surface quality of like one of them is sound
and the other one is color or something like that. I can't I can't remember what it was. So I took that as
it's it's sort of doing both things. I feel like that you guys were talking about there where the the
objective here is to make um emissions as the relational quality um but to then think them as
constitutive of the object that is the atom uh itself rather than as secondary attributes of this atom
so the the motivation of the atom is this kind of emission stuff but that motivation is also prior
it's not just like hey there are atoms and some of them emit
this is a question that I've had for a long time. I I mean I have wondered about this and not just like
during altered states but like I don't know what color is and have found it to be incredibly
confounding. Like does it exist in the world apart from human perception? Because I don't think it I
don't think it does. I I don't I mean I think that there is an answer to this question by the way. Like
I don't think that this is I mean this is the way I understand color and this is the way you know like
when I'm you know sometimes tell freshmen like color doesn't exist the way that you you know we all
know that color doesn't exist the way that you think that it does. And then I once talked to someone
who over the course of our conversation described disguise or described himself as a color realist
and in fact I think I said like would you call yourself a color realist? Like there are colors out
there it's like yeah. I'm like that's odd. But you know I mean like light strikes an object and then
basing based basically on like the topography of the of the surface it reflects off of it and changes
its frequency. So like color it's only in light and it's only based on the pattern and of its of its
movement and then well it's not just but it's also not just in light it's also the receptors of our
eyes, right? Nerve of our particular, right, biology, right? So it's it's it really is an instance of you
know I gave the example many episodes ago in terms of the simulacrum of the large statue, yeah, you know
is a classical example but it's it is it's like that's what color is a really good example of that
simulacrum relationship that that requires an exterior perception. Yeah, in order to even exist. Yeah, like
you can't say the human eye is constitutive of the existence of something called color because you
could say like hey, right, this light wave is you know blue but you couldn't think blue without
interacting with with the human eye, right? Right. And so you would tell you like other animals or you know
any other kind of biology wouldn't see colors the way that we I mean they simply wouldn't, and maybe
Maybe not even see colors, who knows, and they study that in certain animals. I was just watching some
David Attenborough thing where there's a breed of deer in, like, India, you know, who are the primary prey
for for Bengalese tigers, basically, and they can't see orange. Orange to them is green, so the tigers blend
in and can kill them at whim, you know, and it's like so we we obviously see the tiger in the green forest.
They can't see it at all, so from an evolutionary standpoint these deer got really fucked and and even
like, yeah, the very notion of camouflage, by the way, is so idiosyncratic to the human, right? Like, well,
because, you know, these color patterns emerge in such a way that makes humans harder to see other humans
but unless if you're including the perception of other animals or other relevant things like I could be
standing, I might as well have like flashing lights and being wearing polka dots, right? Or when I'm wearing
flashing lights and wearing polka dot I might be straight up fucking invisible to something, right?
I mean the Hegelian point though would be to take that away from the context of color and basically
attribute that that the only reality is the confrontation between, you know, objects and
apparatuses, so like any the stuff of reality is relational, it's it's not just color is a particularly
poignant example because it seems very, that's right, ephemeral, but basically you can attribute that
relational complex to any variety of objects or or stuff out there, you know, right? But it's also it's
it's not even I mean yes we like to take the instances of the the tiger, the Bengal tiger because it's like
really pithy interesting examples but I just think of every day like I mean color blindness, right? Like I mean
so it's you know men have more color blindness but I don't know have you guys you guys have done the
colorblind test at some point in your life? Oh yeah, for this is way more colorblind than me.
Yeah, and you just so I mean if you follow through that thought process a little bit you just realize
like literally people are really just not seeing the same things, like they're just not seeing the
blue gold dress thing. Yeah, the blue gold, yeah, like although that always seems like it was a trick of
the light, or it could be a trick of the light because it's a photograph, yeah, but I just mean like
if you get so it's the same it's the same picture that two people are looking at in real time and
seeing radically different colors but that the upshot would be it's not the same picture, right? Like I mean
that that's what I'm saying if you follow out the line of thinking on this it's not the same picture.
And that and it's not even just those exceptional circumstances it is the banal everyday moment of
walking around in the world, like, yeah, it's you know we operate as if we have a shared space
common sense, you know, like exactly like we operate as if like, well, everyone knows there are these houses
here, there's the water there and the things that I'm looking at, but that's just not that's not how
people are actually like even just humans are actually interacting with those spaces that that
that and that's at least for me that's a pretty mind-blowing thought, right? Like, oh yeah, yeah, I mean
I used to give examples I can't even remember why but I used to have to go on this gloss along these
lines in a few classes that I taught and my two like I had a few examples I was like just imagine
if like your sensory experience was dominated by something like sonar or infrared. Yeah, infrared.
That's a good one, like like a bat or the you know the the porpoise or you know the snake, right?
Right, yeah, I mean in terms of just dogs like dogs sniffing around it's like hey they're they're just
checking stuff out the way that way that we like look around at a news scene they sniff around in a
new scene and it's experientially just so wildly foreign something is every day is a little dog
it's just so wildly foreign like I have no idea what's going on with that that being right right
Yeah, I mean imagine being able to smell food from five miles away or something, right? Like, oh there's
some three days removed. Yeah, yeah, yeah, this is the the great example of this uh I actually really like
the show it's called this invest the investigation it was a Danish uh show on released on HBO about
five six months ago and it was about a murder that occurred in Copenhagen out in a uh a man-made
submarine like a little independent submarine and someone this guy killed this woman and dismembered
her body and dumped it into the bay there and they didn't have the body so they couldn't charge him
with murder, right? Like they and um the way they ended up getting the body was they put fucking dogs on
speed boats and would take the speed boats over this is days later and the speed boats out over this bed
it's a huge bay it's basically an ocean and they could smell a decomposing body under the water
several days later and found the body like in and found the body parts even right like parts of bodies
The dogs would start barking. They would stop there. They would send divers down and they found the body.
And you're like, how in the, that's just how is that not a superpower? Yeah, yeah, I mean, from the from an
annoying Hegelian perspective, like every potential is also like a a closure of potential from like our
perspective, so the reason that our senses are like deadened compared to a dog's we couldn't handle it.
Right, we we couldn't handle it, and we have developed faculties that other ones, right, different faculties
like reason, you know, right, yeah, we got we got chipped. Yeah, we got stuck with reason. They can smell
a dead body underwater, yeah, in the middle of an ocean, yeah, yeah. Alligators have a bite force of a
thousand pounds or whatever. We have a fucking reason. We can jump. Yeah, you know, we'd have to have
a hundred foot basketball rims if we could jump like fleas, but even but even within species, I mean,
that's the next part for me, like even even within the human species, right, that's sort of the range is
so extraordinary as to as to make it impossible to say like hey we have a we have a simple we have the
same experience and we have different perspectives on it. It's like that notion of perspectivism it just
doesn't go far enough. There isn't the same experience with different perspectives. There is just
a differential series. Actually, for me, interestingly enough, the play-doh chunk uh was really good at
explaining series, right, and how how series work, you know, that that last part where it's like hey this
is just it's a connection of divergent series that resonate at some ways in terms of the structure of
the book, um, like why it's written in series, it was like ah this is an appropriate ending or last
uh, last day on on this stuff because it talks about how the series work in this series of different
differential relations.
I'm wondering why then why is it the eternal return of the same, like why why doesn't Nietzsche phrase it
that way? It's just a simple question because it seems clear for at least from Deleuze's articulation
that it's the eternal return of difference. I mean, that would be the more accurate way of describing
that concept. So what is it? Because the same is formally speaking differential relations, right?
So it's just that's just what it is. Okay, so yeah, I mean that's Deleuze's and let me say Deleuze's
reading of Nietzsche on the eternal return is uh distinctive meaning, right? It's not widely shared. Yeah.
Um, and even in here he's like look there are some places where the eternal return is articulated in
as the eternal return of the same. It's just even by Nietzsche, even by Nietzsche, right? Yeah, yeah.
And so even the the eternal return is differently articulated in different places, right? Um, and that's
he's right about that. There is that the the passages in Zarathustra where it's where Zarathustra
reproaches his animals for having made the eternal the eternal return into the a refrain into and I
think that the German is the same old refrain. Yeah, I mean, like the refrain of the same. So there's
really really good reason. But when you think of the very first occurrence of the return return in
is in is the um, the demon that comes at night in The Gay Science and what he says is imagine a
circumstance where this very same night this very same window this me this demon appearing
will occur over and over again. It's it's the same. He says like this the the same everything will occur
recur eternally. Um, so Nietzsche when he sets it up really does define it as the return of the same
right. But I mean, you know, Deleuze it to me to lose his reading is entirely persuasive because all that
returns in the question of the same could only ever be differentiation so it's like if you start from a logic of
identity that then you end up with like the problem is Nate phrased it which is well isn't it really
difference rather than the same? But if you start with the logic of difference, the same is right
difference exactly. Um, so that you're not you don't even have to do that move to complicate the notion
of the same because that's all so it's like oh yeah, it's the same thing that's returning because what
things are what identity is is the sort of residence of differential series. That's it.
Right, you know, right. So yeah, I mean, but it is against the the theological notion of like the return
of God or of you know Jacob or or Christ, you know, so it it is in opposition to you know
those returns are always premise on a whole though because the return is always a matter of completing
what had been fractured. That's right. And that's one of the so there are in there in some of Nietzsche's
notes uh are about this where he sees the eternal return as a kind of cosmic principle where in the
sense that like if you if you took a sheerly materialist like old-fashioned well most materialist view of
this you would say like the eternal return the claim is this given a finite universe and it and uh the
number of particles that it eventually will be, I mean it's just inevitable, right, like given infinite
amount of time and finite universe things will recur and they will not only recur they will recur
infinitely, right? the exact same thing. So and there's there's Nietzsche's notebooks where he's
trying to think through this as a cosmological principle. Now, of course, there's also the existential reading
which is like no Nietzsche's point is live as if every moment that you're living, you know, so there's a
bunch of different variations. I mean that's what to me Deleuze's is just the most compelling one
and they're not incompatible, right? they're not they're not have the the sort of ethical heuristic
you know on top of and you don't just need infinity of of time you just you don't you can have just
infinite space as well, right? that's right that's right that's right yeah
yeah I mean that's the one thing that complicates that though is that in all of those there is
what is maintained is a general specific law of transcendence that would say all right, given
the same set of rules and and an infinite, you know, space or time, then everything will recur and recur
exactly and end infinitely, but the the the logic of invention that Deleuze teases out, you know, all over
his his oeuvre is one wherein those rules are not transcendent and they're constantly evolving and
changing and creating, you know, not just different possibilities within the same sort of general set
of possibilities but entirely new logics of possibilities and now right like if like
that version of of the eternal return gets seriously problematized because now in like
the infinite is way more infinite way more infinite, right? yeah and if you if you think of the eternal
return through like the notion of practice or habit uh Casey Boyle talks about this a little bit in his
book like even the repetition, right? when you think of repetition you think of it in the vulgar sense where
it's like the the exact same task is repeated over the course of days hours weeks so like let's say
you pick up the habit of guitar playing or whatever and you play the same chord progression uh over and
over hour after hour day after day month after month you would think of that as the same exact task
repeated over a different set of times and days but because yeah exactly because of the relational
difference because there's a different you repeating that task there's a temporal delay between each
instantiation it's not repetition in that vulgar sense there's potential for whatever for growth
for regress for intervention yeah exactly right which is why repetition is always pedagogical that
you know within every repetition there are possibilities of breaking and making new alliances
both for our sake but also just for our listeners I I want to kind of like try to
tease out a series of relationships that I see and so I'll start with the the orchid and the wasp thing
which he's thinking you know we tend to think about evolution in a genetic sense which is you know
genes are passed down and then change happens you know evolutionary change happens across um uh
generations you know like these genes get passed down to this generation but something there's an error
in copying or a mutation in copying and that's how evolution happens by the way that's it's one that
always interests me because you're right that notion of evolution is one step mutation meaning some event
occurs that causes a genetic mutation and then selection right I mean that that that's the sort of model for
that version of evolution and but the explanation for mutations I mean the question so then how do
mutations happen and the explanation is always error right some error in the replication process but again
the notion of error this is for you Nate it's always presumed upon a fidelity like in other words well
what what genes are supposed to do is copy themselves exactly despite the fact that they almost never do that
yeah right and you're like at a certain point wouldn't you start going well maybe it's not an error
right like yeah no you need to say what genes do is express which we do have a language for expression
right but we just tend to think about copying an expression a little bit differently and in copying
it's very it's just interesting the way we go from the similar like the fact of similarity to the same
yeah right like we just so quickly and it's like let's live in let's live in the terrain of the
similar because it's way more complicated and way more anxiety producing right well yeah I think that's
the thing because there's a lot of there's a lot of um open-endedness that like you know like no if
this is it's either the same or it works more than it's failed to be the same and I can rush it for
failing to be the same yeah yeah I mean but that that traditional notion though that that genes or the
genetic structure uh aspires to sameness seems completely misguided at least in terms that we're
Talking about because again sameness would prohibit change and development. The error is what's productive
of life. Well, that's where but the solution that biology came up with in the 60s was sexual, right?
Like so so meiosis and it's sort of the the sexual reproduction becomes the way of adding in difference
which is to say what genes are supposed to do is identically replicate, that's what they're supposed
to do, but if you bring in another organism then they're supposed to blend together and then it's okay
so you have a you have like a marriage ceremony built into the biology of genetics which is what
they're left on their own they're supposed to simply reproduce identically but bring something in from
the outside and now you have sex, sexuality, and that's what gives you diversity. Yeah, how do we just not
see just how radically theological science is, right? Yeah, I mean we were introducing, yeah, marriage and error
and I mean it's it's it's sin and and sacrament and sacrament, right? But anyway to finish out on the example
so like he gives uh so with the orchid and the wasp obviously not genetically related to each other
he's like look okay so sure mute evolutionary mutation, evolutionary evolutionary change happens
does happen genetically, i'll never use that whole error copy language, but it does happen, you know, at the level of the gene
it also happens at the level of across have enough that has nothing to do with genes where different
species or different things create alliances with each other that sort of i mean kind of carry out part of
that selection process so you're getting into Lamarckism man, Lamarckism is the uh, you know i mean that's the the
fear and look there's historic stretch my neck long enough and you know i get that that's right i mean that
once you start talking about the sort of uh acquiring the inheritance of acquired characteristics is the
phrase you know once you start talking about that you've moved away from and you know Darwin was
Lamarckian. We don't like to talk about that fact but um but but yeah and you have the the whole Soviet
Union. I mean there's a whole history to the adoption of Lamarckian versions of evolution and the
catastrophic results that literally like people die right like from wheat the the attempt to uh um use
this theory to uh uh grow beans or some shit like that. Well produce, it's produce food, and it didn't it
didn't work, starved the whole population, right? And so yeah, um so so but that's it's like the and there are
people i mean I read a couple books there's a couple of like folks in Australia that are trying
to bring back a kind of new Lamarckism um that is not the kind of if you stretch your neck long
enough or if you cut off your arm your kid's not going to have an arm, you know, it's in other words
it's not taking that simple simple version of sort of somatic versus germ cell differentiation
um but it's it's just met with intense resistance because it's a heresy
well okay i'm not trying to put the religious thing on it but but yeah i mean because it is
outside of the the the dogma of evolutionary theory. I mean this is the extent to i'm obviously on the
outside of this this is i i wasn't 20 years ago because i read a lot of that stuff but and i don't
know maybe the discourse has changed in the last 20 years but i doubt it's changed you have a degree
in biology right? Yeah, yeah. I mean it is odd to me though like the the different registers of
adaptation or evolution like certainly some parts of our evolutionary makeup are very slow and gradual
like why do we still have wisdom teeth, you know, like that's a that's a result of millions of years
and it's just some sort of residue nipples? Right? Right, like why why do we have these things we still
have them and we clearly don't need them, right? And then on the converse, you know, with the the rise of
information systems or when you think about like um what's what's the word like generational trauma or
like inherited trauma where like you know that our generation millennials uh generation z seem to have
adapted quite differently to our circumstances than than previous generations so like the whole psychosocial
um sort of makeup seems to be much more fragile and adaptable than like you know your teeth or your
nipples
There's nothing crazy in saying that some things yeah are swift. I mean because like
just look the the element of evolutionary theory that admittedly this is a more of a popular dumb
version of it is you know that there's a reason for things it's just utterly ridiculous, right? Like
things find niches, things find resonances, things find alliances, but just because something doesn't
have an alliance just because there's not you know like a male nipple reproduction alliance doesn't mean
that like the nipple like out of some lack of necessity is going to go away. It means that it's available for
going away in ways that other things are less likely to go away but i mean it's going to disappear one
Day, I mean, you know, so, like, that's part of the fear of Lamarckianism is that, oh, it's, it's like the same
error between, you know, thinking the similar and the same, all right, like are, are identical or the similar
is the failed same. It's like, okay, well acquired traits doesn't mean that everything you freaking do is
going to require a new genetic trait and that everything is available for for change in that in
that way, and genetics is sophisticated enough at this point to realize that, for instance, it's not
necessarily clear whether or not the existence of nipples is tied to the capacity to reason or something
you know what I mean, like sort of bizarre seemingly disconnected things may genetically be quite, quite
connected, right, um, and and we don't really have a sense of that, you know, when you give birth
you're giving birth to an organism not to a series of attributes, right, so it's not, uh, you know, this
select now we we've got that new, uh, newish, that, uh, um, what's the editing the genetic software? The
genetic editing software, the CRISPR, crisp, yeah, um, so it'll be interesting to see because they're they've
actually, you know, they have, um, I mean I I saw a fairly recent thing, a study that is over three or five
years where they've cured deafness, I mean, and through through genetic editing and that's kind of amazing
right, and it'll be curious if all of them have like glowing ankles or something, you know what I mean?
like some some sort of bizarre random thing that you would never think of being connected to hearing
you know I'm just picking an arbitrary thing, but but you know, like it's it's a sit, you know, we are
one of these differential systems. We it's not we're we're not monads, yeah, you know, right, so, right, yeah
but again that's the sort of I mean the primacy that we that that the way that logic works empirically
in the world is to take differential systems and to translate them into, you know, substance attribute
systems. That's right, right, which one of the reasons I always love thinking about Deleuze as an as
an empiricist is to say, and that's a thing that has, you know, like empirical effects in the world, that's
not, you know, like an illusion or an error that's like a, you know, right, again if empiricism is thought
as some form of relation as opposed to that hard stuff as like entities that are, you know, because
the the example of CRISPR or any kind of genetic modification, how can you think of the essence of
anything when we're able to manipulate our essence in that way? Like the spider goat, you know, that
produces like silk and its milk. I mean, it's like there's no essence of a goat that we're modifying, we're
just creating relations that turn stuff into different stuff, you know, it's like, but I mean the way I mean
culturally we respond to those things as monstrosities and aberrations and and anti-natural and I mean all
all of that when in fact that's all that nature does, right? Like all nature does is sort of puts
things together and produces monstrosities, some of which come to be accepted as not monstrosities
right, you know, yeah, and he has a nice one little sentence in here that nature is conjunctive rather than
essential or whatever. There's an and rather than an is in nature. It's just this and this and this and
the combination of traits or attributes or events rather than essences that are modified, you know, but
it is really interesting, I mean, that during my time in the science studies way, the way the way in which
um I mean, I wouldn't necessarily call it, it gives too much privilege to theology to call it theological, but
there is a metaphysics, um, just built in, of course, to the work of doing. That's why for me I feel like
it's important to not give the word empiricism to certain strands of the sciences, why I want to hold on
to a word like empiricism, um, and say, hey, look if all empiricism means is, you know, stemming from an
experience, right, yeah, that's why that's a range, right? That's a range of possible, right, it doesn't
have to mean as empiricism has predominantly been used as this sort of scientific and again there are
plenty of sciences that are not simply this either, right, that are not simply these these reductive
materialist uh versions of, well empiricism has in many ways been conflated with some version of
analytics or metrics, right, where like what actually matters what we call empiricism is actually measuring
things. It was actually rationality, right, like it's rationalism, right, it's like mathematized experience.
Yes, is what it's like, wait, that was what rationalism? Yeah, wasn't that the whole debate for a really long
time was is it math or is it what you see? Right, they turned into the same thing structurally. They turned
the same thing, right, in a classic Hegelian move, yeah, they're the same
um, but anyway I wanted to just I wanted to continue to think through a relationship between, you know, the
omission of these elements, the omission, uh, and the pedagogy stuff and the alliance stuff, right, that you
know, so on the one hand, you know, you have the orchid and the wasp that are that they create an alliance
with each other and, you know, the i don't even remember what the actual alliance is like that the
the orchid is the site where the wasp is able to reproduce or something like that.
yeah, that's right, the the wasp is a trap. i mean, the the conventional understanding would be
the orchid resembles a wasp. oh that's right. therefore the wasp lands on it to mate, that's
right, uh, and and by doing so spreads the pollen, right, right, right. so by the way that Deleuze is
reading that is that these are different, like, the the, there is some kind of like differential
relationship between the two that now emits all of these possible like um uh that allows for all
these other possibilities and that this actually plays a role not you know the determining role but like
a role in the evolutionary you know path of both the orchid and the wasp and you know really by
conjunction the entire ecosystem, right. so there's that. now think about you know the way he talks
about indifference and repetition, about you know the waves emitting signs that one responds to and
talking about that pedagogically it seems that like you would just totally read that pedagogical
lens into the orchid wasp relationship and just say the orchid and the wasp are teaching each
other. that's why i like the term pedagogy is exactly what you're saying is like pedagogy is not just
what a person does in a classroom or even what they do outside, you know, like it is the natural
phenomenon that's that is i mean i agree with you so i mean that back to the passage that you just
brought us to in in 261 where it's like you know there there are systems like this. there's
signal there they're signal sign systems. a signal is a structure in which the difference of potential
are distributed assuring the communication of disparate uh components so orchid wasp swimmer
wave. right. the sign is what flashes across the boundary of the two levels between communicating
serious like that's the pedagogy that's you know that that flash the sign you know that is creating
the connection between swimmer wave orchid wasp whatever whatever like that's that is what we're talking
about with like a pedagogy from this sort of differential perspective right? yeah. and keep on
going because i i really love that whole paragraph but towards the end of that page, um, he says there is
there is always no doubt a resemblance between resonating series right like this is the question
of the similar rather than the same like they're they're similar uh there's there's a resemblance
between resonating series but this is not a problem the problem is rather the status or position of this
resemblance. let's consider two formulas and this goes back to a point that we've made many times
let's consider the two formulas first only that which resembles differs and second only differences
can resemble each other these are two distinct readings of the world one invites us to think
difference from the standpoint of prior similitude or identity whereas the other invites us to think
similitude and even identity as the product of a deep disparity the first reading precisely defines the
world of copies and representations it posits the world as icon the second contrary to the first
defines the world of simulacra and posits the world as a phantasm right like this is the the basic
the baseline difference and you know this is where he says like so to reverse platonism means to give
the simulacrum uh rise and to affirm their rights among icons and copies right like that's that's
the reversal of platonism doesn't get rid of resemblance and repetition it just sees them
as uh derivative or secondary aspects of of of a a a perpetual self-differentiation their kinds of
differential of differential relations right right i mean look i i know that you you were downplaying
you were saying we're giving too much credit to theology but you know both with Derrida and Deleuze i mean
there's a reason why it's often referred to as ontotheological right and you know the language
calling you know within that first paradigm of the model copies like the world is an icon
right yeah and like the iconography is clearly related to a not just theology theological
theological ontology metaphysics yeah no i i agree i don't think that you're wrong and i don't i
wouldn't say i wouldn't discourage anyone else from using it i'm just never comfortable because to me i'm
always what you're doing what i would be doing is putting religion back as the sort of the baseline
logic for informing all of thinking and and like i just don't want to do that i just i don't want to
do that either i just think that's what has happened and i think that's one of the major things i mean
you know like think about you know Nietzsche the the shadow of uh god is long or there are many shadows
of god rules you know you know this whole atheism thing is a hope is a total hoax because you've just
Replaced God with whatever else, and to me the most glaring the most glaring example of that is
integrating the notion of purpose within evolutionary change, right, like, yeah, I mean that's where that's
that's where Nietzsche gets at the end of Genealogy of Morals. The last thing is like the will to truth
turns out to be the paradigmatic mode, you know, it's like that's that's now where this uh engine
the engine of resentment and the ascetic priest is in the will to truth. That's where it's most evident
right yeah I mean if there's an anti-theological thread in this uh in the appendices here I mean he he's
more explicitly anti-myth right I mean it's like myth is the problem because of it secures foundation
foundation right but I mean insofar he's basically diagnosing theology as any kind of emplacement of
structure in the face of chaos the chaos of relations so I mean it insofar as that is just a tendency
of human being um I don't know if he if Deleuze is saying we need to full sail or wholesale get rid of
that tendency um but he does want to embrace the chaos of the eternal return right I mean the eternal
return is chaos it's not it's not a response to chaos it's sort of an affirmation of that right
right of those relations you know that's right although I do think the next step for me for my
thinking is that that an affirmation of the chaos can also mean an affirmation of sameness right like
in other words you're not picking one or the other right it's not like okay let's have done with this
notion of the same and the similar and let's move to a world of understanding the sort of absolute
differences like well actually one of the way that absolute difference works is through similarity
right and and so therefore it's not necessary it's not necessarily a transgressive relation I mean
the other way of saying it is how do you make yourself a body without organs you already are
right like you know that's kind of a Hegelian point I mean that's what we don't have I mean I don't
there's no point in like really teasing out the differences here because clearly Hegel works as a
figure uh you know a foil for Deleuze's thinking here and it makes sense the way he teases out those
oppositions but I do think you get that kind of thinking of contingency and that prioritization
of difference in Hegel as well it's but the point with the point I think would be you can get it
anywhere right and it's not specially Hegelian or Deleuzian or anything that that given the ontology
it's just the case that everything is you know that all molar entities of any kind are made of lines
of flight and so it's of course totally reasonable for Deleuze to read Hegel as the representational
thinker par excellence even the thinker of infinity within the context of representation but nevertheless
a representational thinker it's also entirely reasonable to go back and like what he has done
to Plato to do Zizek on Hegel and it's not because Hegel's special or Zizek is special it's because
that is the nature of moral uh moral that that is the nature of molar entities is that they are
they are comprised comprised of difference so it's not Hegelian or Deleuzian or any particular
you know uh brand it is just ontological in that sense and it's not even that right like that's too
strong of a claim right right although I mean there is always and you know this was a sort of a recurring
thread in the Hegel tapes was that you know to say that your thing is the same like I can have your
thing in your world you can't have my thing in your world um is also to remember I mean what identity
and similitudes are and look like and how they function are different within a differential ontology
than they are within one based off of substance and that's right and and being um right and so that's
I mean and and that actually raises interesting questions for me is like when you say like yeah
like similitude similitude makes way more sense to me and within a differential ontology because you
like all right well these things sort of like resonate with each other and these things don't and
that's fine right identity is harder for me to think because it would always have to be like
identity to what right you could always say like these dimensions are identical but no way could
all of them be so I just don't know how to make the leap from the similar to the identical
right yeah yeah I mean I I agree with you because if you stay in a kind of headspace of similitudes
similarity things are way more interesting and way more interactive because I I mean I'm with you like
what if you're in the realm that's that's where the argument of like the cogito is not a problem
yeah right like the the cogito as this sort of I I think I'm the self-contained quasi-monadic
thing that goes about and has its adventures that thing's not uh you know it doesn't have the capacity to interact
right it doesn't have the capacity to you know put up strip malls or I mean that's my my own version but
Uh, it's just so that the issue is precisely the porousness of the similar, the the sort of condition
of difference being precisely what allows for and requires relations yeah so that that relations for
anything to exist must be relational right and as a result of that just for our non-Deleusian
listeners just um get a quick gloss on the difference between the molar and the molecular and i know we're
doing this like 18 episodes too late but but you can use any of the term i mean any of the terms they
use like trees or rhizomes you know any of the dualisms that that they deploy to mean you know it's
the like i think of the molecular as the n minus one and the molar as the unificated the notion of unified
identity um or the same and and frankly it's the the only place where it's important is self-identity
it's not i mean that's what's important like to think of something as being simply identical to itself
and that's where a lot you know logic requires that right it requires a notion of self-identity
for logic to work right and and from the from the n minus one perspective once you sort of get rid
of in quotation marks well once you problematize the notion of unity and start thinking differences
constitutive of those you know supposedly molar or unified or cogito type of entities
they're not a problem anymore right you don't have to bust up i mean that's so much of what went under
the name of post-modernism in the night like when i was reading post-modernism in the 90s
right was all attempts to kind of bust this subject-centered cogito notion and to show that like
hey um the the ego or the eye is way more socially constructed and all these types of things that's
a lot of that work was was doing and from this direction why would you bother to do that that
the the the eye or the subject doesn't need to get multiplied or fragmented because it was never
a unity to begin with yeah right i mean so that that particular distinction for me it took me years to
kind of figure out like i mean whenever i read something where Deleuze would talk about the molar
molecular i was like all right well i kind of get what i understand what molecules are we're talking
about parts of my teeth with molar i just don't get what's going on here and you know it's i mean i've
since developed a better sense of it you know because often when he's talking about the molar molecular
um distinction you know it's in reference to the flat playing of ontology where you say like the flat
playing playing of ontology uh faces two sides the molar and the molecular which still like saying that
you know for someone who doesn't understand what the flat playing of ontology is is also totally over
your head but like i think a good example is to take any any item so what you said tree let's take a tree
right and you know one way of thinking about the tree traditionally in an ontological sense is to say
all right there's like an essence to the tree and you know it has an appearance and it has different
qualities and it has sort of like an internal structure and we'd have to sort of like separate
the tree-ness of the tree you know from everything that is sort of accidentally the tree and then now
what we've gotten into is this whole logic that we've been talking about for you know months and months
about like all right there's a general sense of what the tree is there's a specific instantiation
to it and then the whole relationship to it is sort of like one of adjudication or it's like you're in
a law court like what's properly the tree what's not we have to separate the wheat from the chaff and then
you can see how a whole sort of morality of sin and error and failure enters into it but the way that
Deleuze is is undoing that ontology to say like all right let's take something like the tree and we're
going to put it on a flat playing of imminence and we're going to think about the tree from two
different perspectives that are both operative at the same time on the same play place or same plane
so look at one side of it and it's not that hard to imagine the tree is like what the tree is made
up of things right there are different constitutive parts of the elements and what Deleuze will say is
that but we're not thinking about those at a substantial level we're thinking about those at a
differential level so there are all of these sort of like differential intersections interactions
exchanges or whatever else that that sort of make up what we take to be the tree but if you only step
stood on on that side of the plane it would seem then like you know we're into a hermeneutics of
suspicion well it's not really a tree it's just this mirage or this phantasm of a mature of a tree that's
actually sort of like covering over all these other things so what my what my perception is is a false
perception but what is it took me way longer to figure that was easy right for i mean that was
relatively easy for me to figure out i think that's what a lot of Deleuzians do because that's
Rhizome! Half of it. Hooray for rhizomes. It allows us to see through the illusion that all the stupid
metaphysics of being is giving us, which sounds like you're peering into the essence of the
thing, which sounds a whole lot like the opposite of what Deleuze is trying to do, and you have to think
the more or side of it at the same time, like on the other, from the other perspective, the tree is just a
tree, as in like the tree as identical to itself, as as within the conceptual realm of tree, not differential
relationships between soil and sunlight and earth and all of this other stuff. No, it's it's a it's a tree.
It's a logical tree, and that tree is also operative at the on the flat plane that interacts with other
molar entities like chainsaws and wood-burning fireplaces and whatever else, and at the same time
all of those molecular relationships as well. So what that is effectively doing, and I said this a bit
earlier, is thinking, you know, the ideational, conceptual, logical, linguistic dimensions of our world around
us not as being elevated or transcendent but actually operative, empirically operative, you know, on the
same plane. Be like, look, a tree is not uh an idea that's floating above and you can correctly match
things to the tree or falsely correct or like um uh uh match them to the tree. It's it's just another
variable on the board that is interacting with everything else, right? Right? Yeah. And the molar can
have retroactive effects on the molecular and vice versa. I mean, like, we were just saying, like, you were
saying in terms of post-modernism, I think also, I mean, Descartes is still the enemy, is still the explicit
target of new materialism, etc., right? So the molar is considered the enemy of a contemporary um, you know,
theoretical and ethical framework where it's like, you know, we you want to unearth the complexity of the
molecular, you want to attend to and embrace that difference in order to accommodate the complexity
of the world and the ethical implications that that implies. But I think Deleuze and like you
were just saying, Nathaniel, um, I mean, your orientation through this is not, it's not a simple you can't
just say no to the molar, which seems to be like the the tendency of of a lot of uh contemporary theory, I
guess going back to the whole post-modernist movement, you know, or or break up unities, right?
That's I mean so so there's a notion of the part whole, and there are the there's the the one and
the fragment, right? Like everyone for a long time when I was in graduate school, everyone was interested
in the frag fragmentation as a kind of positive quality because the fragmentation was shattering
and breaking up. I mean, you think of Diana's like breaking up a total like right, the the notion of
breaking up unities and fragmenting unities was incredibly, it was a it was a project that
a lot of people were intellectually invested in. But that was for me the notion of a fragment.
It doesn't make sense without presuming the existence of a whole at least hypothetically in
some dimension. And so it's like it's never a question of fragments, and it's never a question of
advocating the parts or advocating the molecular as against the molar. If that's the case, we really are
playing a conventional Hegelian game. We are switching, you know, this this notion of unity
for just smaller versions of unity, you know? Um, and so if if molecular simply means as it does in the
sciences a smaller version of molar, right? Or if the de-centered classroom means instead of a teacher we now
have students as the centers, you haven't changed anything. I mean, that's not fair, you have of course
changed something. You haven't changed what you thought you changed, right? That's right. This concept does
not do what you think it does, right? You know, your your change is flipping, you know, you're going from
one side of the coin to the other side of the coin, but you're you're still involved in the same the
same type of game. And I take that to be the basis for your beef with Barad, right? Is that if we relate
it back to the Genealogy of Morals, it's like look, she's really cool when she's sort of busting up the
Butler kinds of, you know, certain types of materialist moves, but then she cares about the truth and thinks
she has it, and because she has not problematized the will to truth itself, everything that she's saying
in terms of meaning and matter in their relationality is suspect or is is is problematic on a different
level. All she's done is busted up total, a series of what we once thought of as totalities and forged
fragments from them, right? And and in terms of accomplishing, I mean, that's a different it's just
a different kind of intellectual project than the projects of the folks that we are primarily interested
in, right? Right? And the the assumption of surpassing the previous paradigms, that's right, is always one
of the issues too, like to me, and like you're saying you don't have to advocate for a post-human subject
that all of a sudden accommodates the complexity of the material or techno social world. The subject the
Cogito, like for instance, was always already dispersed. You don't have to argue for a dispersion of the
cogito, I mean obviously you can argue against Descartes. There are vulgarisms in Descartes, but his version of
subjectivity is symptomatic of a kind of thinking that still kind of insinuates itself into theory
today, you know, well, and it's all of us whether we want it to or not right, to that extent, but but
you're right, I mean, so the question of the politics of theory in this regard is like what is it trying
to accomplish in the polis, and certainly there's the argument, and I understand the argument of like
look, people behave like as if they are or want to be sort of centered essences that go go about
their world, and yes, they have experiences and it folds back onto them, and there is this sort of
buildings Roman, uh, dimension to it, you know, so but on one level you could say well, hey, what they're
doing is not that anyway, right? It's not an ego going out into the world, it is, I mean, so that they've
misunderstood what is what it is that they're doing, and if they understood it differently
they would act a little bit differently, that their comportment would be shifted, and that's the
a kind of consciousness raising project that is implicit, the implicit politics of a lot of the
theory world is, you know, if people understood their actions, if they understood their relationship to
alterity, for instance, I mean, I see this all the time, right? If they realize the extent to which their
constitution is dependent upon alterity, they would be a lot more caring and gracious and hospitable of
alterity, you know, to which my response is fuck you, right? Like, I mean, I mean really, like, and I mean, and I
mean that seriously, yeah, with, you know, in terms of the incredible dismissal, like that's my instantiation
of a welcoming of alterity, and and so like if you take the thinking that for me the thinking is like
it doesn't matter whether people know or think that uh or not on any political scale that they're already
doing it, they're already doing their sort of distributed subjectivity, they're just doing it in a particular
way, and yeah, of course would we would i like to create ecologies of different ways of performing your
distributed subjectivity? Yeah, i there's politics that i'm very interested in, they just don't ever have
anything to do with movements, but that's a different question, right? right? yeah, I mean I take that to be what
you're interested in, yeah, like what what what sticks in your crawl, or you know, with with Barad is that
she wants to become a new religion, or she wants to become a new I mean that's the you know, we're
connecting it to the but uh, you know, that she wants to offer the new thing, right? And and the projects
you'd be like look, it's not about a new thing, it's about creating possibilities for all kinds of
right? yeah, dispersion, and the the Hegelian warning is just that, you know, all the the vulgar categories that
people attribute to Hegel not wrongly, I mean he does have like these there's reason the understanding
there's all these faculties of consciousness, Barad's aim is to deconstruct them and allow us to, you know,
accommodate a difference that is irreducible to those categories. The Hegelian warning is that
those categories are going to insinuate themselves in some some version of that movement of thinking is
going to, you know, habituate itself uh, in various contexts, so but I mean again it's not catching
Barad like saying like oh you're a closet Hegelian, you know, but it's just it's just a warning, it's like
the aspiration of her theory which is to supplant uh conventional theory with a new ethical theoretical
paradigm. It's just like right, you know, it's it's a lot harder than just saying now we're relational, you
know, yeah, well no, I mean it's it's and that's where I mean for me if i'm describing my politics in terms
of the theory world I am just a hard coordinate chain, which is it's overcoming the human and every other
task is right, you know, kind of inconsequential in relationship to that, it is overcoming, and now what
does overcoming mean and what does the human mean that gets complicated, but like no, there's not a
solution in so far as you're dealing with humans, no yeah yeah there isn't for this this is our species
being, right, this is what we do is we we bring metaphysical premises as i'm doing even as i'm
saying this, right, i i'm doing it and can't help but doing it, and the problem is not one that is
resolvable, and it's it's just not resolvable by our speed, we're not capable of a kind of thinking
that would be necessary uh in order to to really think relationally, we're not, right? And the best
you can do I mean that's where Nietzsche time and again the best you can do is, you know, be the child
bearer for the overman, it's never it's never I mean when Nietzsche describes it's interesting because
everyone you know go over man go over man but whatever Nietzsche describes it, he's always talking
about may your wish be to give birth to the over, right? It's never may your wish be to be the over
Man, it's may your wish be to create the conditions that allow for a a mutation that's of substantial
difference, but it creates something else, right? It's a horizon rather than an actuality, you know.
Right, right, it's you know and and Derrida talks about this in terms of the the messy the messianic
without messianism in his in his marked book, in other words the the telling of a coming without the
God, right? Like, um, so that's I mean, and that is I think it is that that sense of uh futurity
that is constitutive for me at least, that's the political dimension. It's not like hey go relations
and I and I and by the way I'm going to be able to show you these people are thinking relationally
and those people aren't thinking relationally. It's like well to me you just gave everything up
right? Like if you can show me people who aren't doing relationality then you've given up the project
that's right, you know, but what they care about is that these people don't know they're doing
relationality or they tell me they're doing that's and so then it becomes so that's right so then it's
a consciousness raising project then it became and that's not nothing and I don't want to say that
it's nothing but that is one particular it's like if more people were aware of the status of
relationality in their lives they would behave differently and that may be true, right? Like I
mean I'm not saying that it's not I think that they're I'm sure they would behave differently but
maybe not in the predictable way that you're hoping they will.
Well that right, exactly, like hey we problematize truth and we see what we got politically.
Good job guys, I mean yeah I mean that's I mean that's it's a good example in the insofar as like
what what we experience and are still experiencing in this sort of Trump you know moment is precisely
like well we can just call truth whatever we want to call it that sort of the cheap relativism
as a kind of backlash I mean but when I was in graduate school everybody was complicating notions of
truth and now the chickens have come home to roost in a sense right because it's like okay now the
right has taken that argument which is who gives a shit what the experts say is truth truth is what I
decide is truth like that's how it ended up playing out and you start going well maybe we shouldn't have
simply said bust up the molar entity that is truth in favor of something else. It's like we we actually
like that truth thing an awful lot let's you know let's stick with that you know right yeah
there are versions of truth that are still valuable and we should probably hold on to them
of course right like I mean again to me the issue is the will to truth yeah yeah right like that that's
that's the thing that is certainly Nietzsche's target right like the the desire for the answer
right that is the thing that creates like okay basically it's a desire to not have to think anymore
like once once I know that you're a terrorist and I can put you in that category then I don't have to deal
with the complexity once I know you're a criminal once I know you're black once I know you're a woman
you know it's it's that perpetual like I want to not have to think and respond to otherness right
except for categories gives me away to go back to the you know the notion that you know in some ways
it's essential to our the survival of our species that we can't smell dead bodies you know in the lake from
you know three days ago um it's the same thing is true with the category of temples is like that's
that's essential to our survival if if we had to think about everything all the time
holy shit we'd all be dead yeah that's why the problem is the human
that's why it's not like hey if people were better it's like no no they'd still be people yeah
exactly yeah yeah I mean that that's why those ethical demands or policies are are always just
they they they know they neutralize the theory almost like once once you move into the prescriptive
tone of a lot of contemporary theory it dulls all of the conceptual work which which was often great
like it's like good concept concepts concepts and then this is what we have to do and you're like oh well
that kind of ruined the whole thing and yet every and and the the impulse to do that I mean it's
everywhere it's in every article it's in every book it's in you know you never I mean the thing
that I've been most criticized for in my writing is that I don't come down on a side and I'm like
do you think I just forgot that do you think it just didn't you know what I mean like it's and
not that I'm not that my work is somehow so it's not you know but whatever it's just the demand
out there to have well but then tell us what the answer is like then so you told you showed us all
these things that style is not so what is it? It's like right is is the problematic word there yeah I
mean you know but it's it's it's not very sellable i mean it's not um no it's not it's not even a
function of the discipline when you think about the conventions of the publishing industry you need to
have a saleable object or a pedagogy or something you know here's my thing well it's not even just
that you need an object of study is that the object of study needs to be needs to fit within a set of
predefined categories like the object must be substantial in some kind of way like that needs
to have i mean not you know in the physical sense but there needs to be you need to be able to say that
it is something well and it needs to be transferable so people need to be like say this is the pedagogy
i can now mobilize that in my classroom or i can mobilize this theoretical apparatus and put it over
here and like neatly just kind of you know it's like some content summaries you need to be able to
back to my article is to is to treat i mean the to me the most problematic dimension of an ontology of
substance is the the the make the capacity to make discrete and make exchangeable right so to treat
knowledge as you know not just discrete bodies but exchangeable bodies that can be as you said applied
taken from one context and applied in another way with and still saying the same thing yeah uniformly like
that that's the issue it's like look all we're talking about is relationality so all we're talking
about is application right in a sense but application means differentiation it doesn't mean so it's it's
this sort of almost scientific right like there's there's one of the basic reasons why humanists of all
stripes and scientists don't get along is that scientists believe in repeatability and humanists don't
and yet humanists in in their work say uh my conclusion is something that could play out in
your neighborhood if you were to apply that it's like well you're acting like a scientist you know like
you are taking the very thing that you don't like from the sciences and and making it and building
it into your humanistic like that you can provide an answer
you